la rencontre qui s'ouvrira ce jeudi à
rome va réunir des évêques de partout
dans le monde c'est le pape françois qui
les a convoqués
un événement qualifié d'historique par
des observateurs le vatican estime que
ce sont les évêques qui sont en grande
partie responsables de la catastrophique
gestion de crise de la pédophilie au
sein de l'église des experts spécialisés
en agression sexuelle sont aussi invités
à participer à l'événement de même que
des victimes de prêtres
cette rencontre à huis clos doit surtout
permettre à l'église de saisir la
gravité de la situation
le vatican affirme que les survivants
des agressions commises par des prêtres
doivent être en tête de ses priorités
pourtant l'église est accusée de fermer
les yeux depuis des décennies seulement
depuis un an
de nouveaux scandales ont éclaté au
chili en australie et dans plusieurs
états américains
le pape françois joue aussi sa propre
réputation
les scandales de pédophilie menace de
faire sombrer son pontificat
[Musique]